Today was a beautiful but very rainy day on the farm,
and I was craving homemade bread,
homemade jam. So we got started on iron corn sandwich bread.
So we put in milk, eggs,
oil, dumped in our iron corn flour,
kneaded that together, and then we dumped it onto a flowered surface
and kneaded it until it was nice and smooth.
And I shaped them into two loaves and let them rise.
And after that, we got started on peach jam,
because I got a bunch of peaches from a friend,
and the peaches this year are so good.
They're huge and they're so sweet.
Lois was in a prep mood. She loved peeling and cutting all the peaches,
so she just stood at her station and was my little worker
for about an hour. Was awesome.
Then we realized we had to go milk the sheep.
So got everyone bundled up and went outside.
At this point, it stopped raining,
so we got the milk pill washed,
we got the feed out, we got my six use in their head locks,
eating their grain. I milk them all for six use.
I'm getting about a gallon and a half of sheep's milk,
and it's my liquid gold. It's so good.
I love it so much. So after we got that strained and in the fridge,
we got served on the Peach Dam.
So I dumped all the prepped peaches into big pot.
I put some fresh thyme, I Kind of wanted an Herbie jam,
so we put some fresh thyme,
a bunch of our honey, then they added some lemon juice as well,
and that's all I put in the jam.
Then I got the jars prepped,
put them on the oven so they were nice and hot,
and prep the lids, and then I dumped the hot mixture into the hot jars,
and voila. That was it.
So easy. And it was literally the best peach jam I've ever had.
So we cut the bread, put some French salts,
homemade butter jam, had it with a glass of milk.
It was a perfect rainy day treat.